now welcome to this video about round
five of the bill grandmaster tournament
held currently in bill switzerland yeah
skip done round form with the video I'm
so briefly here what happened yesterday
yesterday and we got some first win by
Corona camera so he's on the scoreboard
after fold with win finally here after
he had lost them earlier against one out
he won yesterday a very long very
fighting game against them Victor Borge
on after very yeah very up-and-down kind
of game where he might also have ya been
worse at one point but it was really a
fighting effort also we had another win
by one how he beat arnesh kira with
black surprisingly had a very nice
position out of the opening a king's
indian and I one very convincingly with
blacks I won how really playing a great
tournament and we had cards and drawing
with like against back row he managed to
get something out of nothing but at the
end it was just the drawn maybe some
chances that Magnus missed them yeah and
today's round we M got even another win
by Wang Hao here beat with white victor
bowleg on who then started with two
losses into the event so he took yeah I
took her nose which place who lost the
first two games and lost now two games
himself so an unlucky spotted seems I'm
but one Hal now with four wins out of
five rounds with a brilliant tournament
the tournament of his life up to now um
the I'd we gotta draw by by a causal
today with arnesh Giri cousin played
very young silver looking opening maybe
got a little bit but really couldn't
yeah get to win and the featured game
today which are present us like a more
begins the back row so let's let's start
here and cacao starts with 1d for he
mixes his moves but here's some deform
opening and back row sticks to his guns
he seems to have prepared the Kings
Indian for this event and plays it again
despite earlier losses Monte Carlo ops
here for for the classical variation and
here slide surprise hikaru blaze d5 p.m.
the petrossian variation which is yes
somewhat out of fashion um it was some
much more popular in them yeah in the
90s some time ago already when Cromley
can played this and quite often also to
beat Kasparov in some fantastic games so
I'm the petrossian know certainly a
slight surprise for back row yeah Black
now has various answers he played a 5
which is by far the main move and now
the carib plays Bishop g5 yet this also
shows some one idea of the Petrosian
this is not yeah not cancelling too
early white wants to keep his options
open and with this Bishop g5 movie also
pins them on f6 night so that black
cannot easily get in the quick counter
play that is used to in the Kings Indian
like let's say night somewhere to age 5
or 8 and then push at five I cannot do
that due to the pin so um he first team
kicks this bishop and it keeps the the
pinna life and now black plays Knight 86
the setup on the queenside is some
designed to prevent white from playing a
three before easily so this a 5 pawn and
the night both on point to the be four
square and the night also to see 5 so
that white cannot easily advance on the
Queen
side white now goes 92 which is a very
common losing those kind of structures
the knight on f3 is in place so well it
dumb it's better off on d 2 because it
covers the sensitivity for square where
black might start its count to play with
f5 and it also is ready to be used on
the queenside most often on c4 sometimes
on b3 but c4 is much more coming and the
other thing is it prepares the move f3
to support the center and give wide the
retreat square for the bishop so this
fits very well like now Queenie 8 which
is also the the main move in the
position yeah he wants to get rid of the
this this pin so that the night can
actually move white castles now and
black plays h5 this move from intense to
ya to add one point activate the bishop
on h6 at least as usual intention we see
in the game that a pro doesn't and
doesn't do it but this is the idea black
could also play more straightforward
stuff like let's say night night here
but this doesn't have with with this
problem bishop in general in the
petrossian it's um often that like
doesn't play so straightforwardly on the
King side we see in the game that like
can play this way but it's uh yeah it's
rather risky well we'll see what happens
so age five and a three young with the
attention of playing before note that
white is really threatening this move if
black would play em I'm complete nothing
move young and i'll just make a silly
with King h8 it doesn't make no sense
but just want to show then they're still
before it's a motive well worth
remembering because this is a pin and
the night cannot take because the rope
hangs
so need to be careful sometimes before
some threat even with night on a six at
the pawn on e5 but ok king edge aight of
course is cecilia move like now plays
Bishop e7 and now the rook is protected
by the Queen so that reef I actually
would lose upon and also I'm black with
Bishop to d7 yeah um poses am a sudden
I'm positional threat here he threatens
the move a form which would hinder wide
from advancing on the queenside because
of this I'm pants on capture this is
also a wide place b3 and there are also
lines where the white even allows this
a4 move but on this arm completely
different in nature where I can play it
stuff like an eye to be five it's very
different b3 is the normal and
strategically sound move why just wants
to prevent this a for stuff and wants to
prepare before and let's say with root
be one and then reform like no place 930
2h7 which is the dual purpose move it
done allows this Bishop h6 so that night
is not hanging on f6 and it brings the
possibility of f5 into the position yeah
white not played f3 because black
head-to-head thread actually this was g5
if he would play let's say here to get
going on the queenside then black and
play this very simple stuff and win the
bishop so wyd needs to spend a move here
and this is why i three was played and
in this position on a crow plays f5 and
this this looks like a very natural
kings in the air move but in fact it's a
rather unpopular move and it doesn't
have a very good reputation I'm very
surprised that he that he chose this I'm
the normal way to treat this position is
real
Bishop h6 with the idea of activating
your bishop on only three and quite
often white even allows this activation
because it sometimes questionable how
good this Bishop really is so a typical
line would be rook be one check here and
like we routes this yeah 22 a funny
position bit and it might continue
something like this Quincy one and then
maybe f5 takes and their form and this
is a rather typical position for the
petrossian mainline it's very difficult
to play this kind of position and it's a
very young unbalanced kind of kind of
game certainly interesting to play this
I think with both colors actually so um
this is the way this is normally played
so Bishop aged 6 to activate the bishop
or I'll get rid of it so on a black
white can also AM am at the moves I can
make a non-issue page six you can also
go here but this has certain yeah other
other implications for instance if like
then plays 95 you cannot easily play
before here because this piece is just
saying or alternatively like might
consider on before to capture d2 would
not be three to come so Bishop f2 is
also on um again also it's got some
drawbacks okay so but let's return to
the game but rope red f5 and the camera
play just drop be one continuing with us
normal plenty of before and here back
row played g5 Bishop retreats and
therefore so you just place them in
typical Kings Indian fashion
on the Kings side but the difference
here is the point is white is got the
ideal setup for his pieces for the Queen
side it's got the night on the two ready
to jump to see for this kind of stuff
after after this move is played and this
night also at this Bishop also supports
c5 and one problem for black is
sometimes in those positions were black
attacks on the Kings side is got this
night over on the Kings side somewhere
like g6 or h6 he's helping in the attack
and this night also doesn't do much from
the attack am all in all this kind of
position has a very bad reputation for
black and I'm really surprised why back
row went into this we can see in how the
game goes it's very difficult to point
out any improvements for him so on yeah
watch us play before here quite normal
and now played Queen g6 to support the
g4 move and white gets in c5 so it's
very quick on the queenside and the
problem also this night is it's really a
bad piece it's as awesome yeah it's a
target really for white we can see them
how this proceeds black plays chief for
now and wide now with the very strong
word same not difficult to see but very
strong move for our c6 just attacking
the bishop and yeah like it took white
also and now if like would take this
bishop you simply have this move and you
win a piece of the game alternatively
take on a six and play we fight you just
win apiece so black cannot take this
pawn and what should you do this Bishop
is attacked it moves to e6 and now wide
place b5 and he's so quick on the
queenside black is really am yeah
getting demolished them he now went
night be 8 which is of course
yeah pretty much equal to two
surrendering this game this is the Sun
nidus is just dead on b8 it doesn't have
firm as doesn't have a square and the
only hope now for black and sound yeah
sort of desperate King's heart attack um
he also could have gone to c5 but this
doesn't help so much also white can play
various things but I think b6 is one
thing which is quite strong let's say
like tanks he cannot allow b7 or taking
on c7 take here and now if black plays
g3 you can just grab on c5 and play on
Bishop c4 jump takes and this typical
sidestep keeping the Bonin on h2 and I
think black is some yeah basically lost
here the sea porn will decide wyd also
threatens the move like a c7 let's say
something like this you play c7 and also
use this this kind of pinning business
so it's just it just lost if white plays
and why doesn't blunder he will win the
game so I'm really mysterious opening
choice by black iam so after this is
some it's really a matter of a good
technical play converting an advantage
and like a word that's a good job I
think so night v8 was played and now wyd
went 95 which is very straight forward
end and a good move the night simply
threatens only 7 winning the Queen and
on c7 so like has some no alternative he
needs to he needs to get get rid of this
piece um if you would consider instead
something like this white can break
through also this is also winning
instantly I think you just have this
this night which is close to in this
kind of position just imagine queen bee
three and then this night is just gone
it's um it's just
room so he took it on d5 not much choice
but this also yeah removes the light
squared Bishop which is absolute
absolute Lee important detecting piece
on the Kings side so another move like
you like to play white recaptured and
now you see that this night has a very
nice square on d to it can jump to it
for now at the appropriate moment yeah
g3 of course black needs to try
something why just them of course move
the the bishop of where you you can
almost never take on g3 it sir it's just
too risky just maybe even this is
playable but this kind of stuff Yemm is
it's always a cause for concern you
don't want to do that so just this one
keeps the the position closed on the
King side yeah 95 trying to get down
something against the king and now I'm
known a camera replace them I think a
very good move it's maybe not the best
move in terms of let's say computer a
large calculation but it's a very human
move and a move that you really should
yeah keep in mind using rooks on the
third usually suffer the third rank but
here it's even the fourth rank roo can
do lots of good work on ranks here the
fourth rank is also quite widely because
black might try to play before at some
point to to get some some air for his
Bishop on g7 and this rook just protects
all those squares it protects d 4 + d 4
+ can do all kinds of nice maneuvers to
the King side so we will see later that
this is really a nice multi-purpose move
which helps why to improve and
yeah it gets options away from black
what's very essential here black is
playing with the piece down on v8 the
only thing that white needs to do is
yeah not get meat and open up the
position unless blankets and some cheap
mating trig white as winning you just
let's say take off the Queen's and black
just resins this position because yeah
white wins on the queenside against this
is basically a lost night okay so a very
good move rupee form and black one age
from of course you need to use what's
what's left them on the on the King side
and 94 blocking this this important
square and keeping this Bishop bad age
three so black throat everything into
the fire ah I missed one one thing here
which I had looked before an alternative
here which shows that easily you can
sport even the best of positions if
white would go h3 here which looks quite
natural to keep the kingside close like
might play this move and yeah well he
threaten ignite h3 and there's nothing
you can do to prevent this but it's
getting really a bit weird now let's say
why play some something move and like
and just take just have a look at this
kind of stuff it can get hairy very
quickly so you really don't want that
age three just gives gives the point of
attack to black it's just a weakness
there this pawn okay but the camera
plateless just just fine deep it nightly
frog-leg played h3 and here on he
decided to take the spawns off at one
point here you need to clarify the
situation f takes G
I'm here an alternative we should look
at quickly as taking on g2 here I'm
sorry um until you can see 11 nice point
let's say this happens then why'd
actually can play something like this
and you see that Lucas just brilliantly
placed on the fourth-ranked here White
has some yeah completely killed blacks
desperation attack and we'll check on
the the kingside himself after all he's
got an extra piece this this thing is
not playing so I'm a nice line to
illustrate the merits of the rookie on
the phone rang okay like it took took he
on g3 and um here yeah White has
multiple ways to win but you think it
shows a pretty good one Queen d2 which
tries to ya force issues here with with
the night at this in this position and I
think buckroe could have fun yeah put up
some what the tougher resistance he
played a rookie form but maybe you
should have tried to capture in g2 and
some maybe it's it's an idea sets whiter
more problems at a possible line King
King takes on g2 and now black has the
somewhat shocking move 9h three the
point being if white takes then this
this check is some quite dangerous kingi
to Queen h2 is just made so I'm okay can
put it on the board behold so you need
to you need to take the pawn and then
Bishop h6 gets gets really hairy the
only thing that white can do is 95
it takes and ruchi form and this one at
the end it's Sam yeah even this is
rather good for white but I know it
looks like tougher resistance I think
it's why deserve is an exchange down but
look at this this is not a piece so
white still be winning here with this be
sick thread but all this some seems to I
think muddy the water at least a bit so
I think I'm maybe should have tried to
instead of Rugare for take here on
another line which is rather interesting
here after this this is white could also
take here but this leads to somewhat
murky positions even King f2 and if
white wants to escape but i don't know i
mean like it's some nice little worse
and probably lost but it looks like i
know a little bit of chances to to maybe
get some swindling you look at the game
he played them as mentioned rookie form
and now white just grabbed on g5 queen
retakes and takes h3 and you're just you
like this night yeah the nidus the trick
piece yeah where you might get something
in and now this is just this is just
over Queen here Bishop g3 and white
repels all kinds of at acxiom it's just
nothing now why does this piss up and
black doesn't have a really tacky try to
take on h3 when Dwight can just capture
all there is and here like resigned he
doesn't have any kind of counter play
not even a check so um yeah a very
clean-looking win for you
corona camera he um he he i'm actually i
think it didn't ya need to even play his
best year or let's say it wasn't a huge
challenge him because simply this kind
of play his it's rather weird at least
after this i mean maybe you can play a
five i even found a game of gericke
spirals with f5 but he didn't close the
position now with g5 and f4 he played 95
or something in this position against
Romney gonna in a rapid game but this
this some kind of formation is simply I
think not playable and I looked it up in
the database they're just just to to
demonstrate this this position I found I
think 11 games in the database and white
has caught not ten and a half points so
he's got a 97 something with percentage
score 95% whatever so what this is just
not playable um no idea what what the
crew was thinking in played this or
rather quickly also maybe you confuse
the move on or something yeah okay what
what does this mean we have 4 10 in the
lead with this huge four winds out of
five games but la camara is also in the
hunt again after his two wins bill uses
a 3-point scoring system so this two
wins and one loss is rather okay you get
six points for for the winds and yeah I
think our chances are intact for my
cameras but it will be hard to catch one
how with his four wins his is just
incredible yeah thanks for watching the
video hope you liked it and i think i'll
do some mob you coverage over the
weekend yeah thanks and bye